[Music]
I looked at a number of cases of groups
being in very demanding circumstances I
looked at a sample of shipwrecks for
example 20 cases of groups of 19 or more
people stranded for two or more months
on isolated shores I looked at the
Shackleton expedition I looked at the
mutiny on the bounty and the Pitcairn
Island errs I've looked at groups of
scientists that were self isolated in in
Antarctica for nine months on on their
own I've looked at all of these there
and more types of groups of people and
the role that leadership might play in
them and how natural selection may have
shaped our desire for leadership and our
capacity for leadership I've also looked
at evidence done by other scientists on
primate groups in the role of leadership
in primate groups including experiments
in which the primate the leading
primates were experimentally removed
from the group to see how the group
functioned after removal of the leader
and all of this evidence tends towards a
set of conclusions one of which is that
human beings are equipped for and prefer
a kind of mild hierarchy we don't want
leaders that are too powerful or too
autocratic or are too able to impose
punishment on ourselves and there's a
lot of evidence that in ancient times
what human beings did in those types of
circumstances is that the lower guys on
the totem pole kind of bonded together
to kill a person who was too violent or
too aggressive or exercising too much
control over the group so this is known
as the self domestication hypothesis the
idea that we humans made ourselves more
peaceful in part by weeding out those
among us that were too autocratic
or too capable of inflicting harm on
those below us furthermore however we
are not too egalitarian we we don't want
groups in which everyone is equal in
status or equally capable and and this
this evidence comes from a number of
sources one piece of evidence for
instance looks at the the role of
inequality even in forager groups so
there's something known as the Gini
coefficient which varies from zero to
one it's a measure of economic
inequality but
can also look at other kinds of
inequality zero is perfect equality
everyone for instance has the same
amount of money and one is perfect
inequality one person has all the money
everyone else has nothing even amongst
and in the United States the inequality
the Gini right now is about zero point
four in Scandinavian countries it's
about zero point two among forager
populations it's about zero point one to
approximately it's not zero so even in
forager populations there's some natural
inequality that's that's present and
furthermore when you look at forager
populations forager populations have
other ways of communicating hierarchy
and status so what what what human
beings care about is not just status but
we also care about prestige so we don't
just care about individuals who are
powerful we care about individuals who
have prestige because they are
knowledgeable so the argument goes that
evolution has shaped us for two
conflicting ways of achieving some kind
of hierarchy one has to do with how
strong you are in essence and one has to
do with how much you know so we value
people who know stuff so to make the
long story short we're interested in
leaders who manifest a kind of mild
hierarchy who know more than we know who
maintain our ability to work together by
kind of tamping down on violence and
conflict but who are not themselves
autocratic and if you look at
well-functioning teams in the examples
that I mentioned earlier often you find
exactly that kind of leadership for
example Shackleton in the Shackleton
expedition and this was about thirty
guys that were stranded for a couple of
years during a failed exploration of
Antarctica Shackleton famously imposed
strong leadership like he there was
someone who challenged his leadership
and he tamp down on that but he was a
kind of benevolent dictator he said that
all food rations should be shared
equally in fact he surrendered his
rations to other people you know one of
the shipwrecks that I studied the
Grafton wreck which took place on the
South Auckland Islands in 1846 South
event arctic north of Antarctica south
of New Zealand
in the Grafton five men were stranded
for about two years
they had extremely capable leadership
but one of the things that they did is
is they agreed to democratically elect
their leader they agreed to be able to
replace their leader whenever they
wanted and they started a school in
which they affirmative Lee made efforts
to teach each other things in which case
they took turns on who was on top so one
day you're teaching me Norwegian the
next day I'm teaching you Portuguese one
day you're teaching me algebra the next
day I'm teaching you how to make shoes
and so they had a kind of school in
which they took turns teaching and
learning and they were explicitly aware
of the fact how these reversals tended
to build solidarity in the group even
though they also had an acknowledged
leader so I guess I would sum up by
saying that some of the lessons from all
of this evolutionary and historical
material that are relevant to leadership
is that you want some but not too much
hierarchy complete egalitarianism is not
good for groups nor is too much
hierarchy you want leaders who are able
to foster connections friendships and
cooperation among their subordinates and
you want leaders who who know things
that their subordinates don't know and
you want leaders who can acquire status
not because of the cost that they can
impose on their subordinates but rather
because of the benefits they can confer
to their subordinates
[Music]